The real lesson is in the moves.
It's not in the content of the points at any place.
So when I'm reading it, I don't get disturbed when I get to that point three or four.
I'm just like, well, forget about the previous ones and now start, you know, because it's
really about every time you think it's this thing, that's going to turn out to be mediating
another thing.
And we're just going to keep doing that.
I mean, there's going to be no end point and it's just going to be the continual like, hey,
now we're at the truth.
And by the way, four pages later, the thing we thought was the truth turns out to not be
the truth, but only a pseudo truth.
And now we're at the truth and you go, okay, got it now.
And then four pages later, you know what I mean?
Like it's, that's just going to be incessant.
And it's just that that's the, that is the progression is constantly feeling a sense of
certainty and constantly having that certainty undermined by some later realization that,
well, yes, you were certain, but it wasn't true.
Or so, you know, that's how he phrases it for a series of sections there.
So I find it less stressful, but, but that's, that's similar to what I said last time of
like, I feel like I could read this for 10 more years, even, you know, and before I really
got it.
It's like, and I would also say, you know, for me, this particular chunk working back through
this, um, I really felt like, oh my God, I, I feel like I'm a Hegelian.
You know, I feel like I, I, in the sense that I have ended, I can think of three recent things
that I've written and published where I do a flip move at the end that, uh, and people
read them and I get the responses all the time.
Like that PNR thing that I did where I'm like, there are four ways of doing this.
And by the way, they're all part of the first way of doing it, you know, and it's just the
last paragraph that does that.
But I've done that in my response to Diane Davis, I do it right at the end of, you know,
and I'm like, that's straight out of Hegel, right?
Like it's, that's, that's just the move that he makes and he makes it, he makes it
every couple of pages, right?
I mean, he does it much more incessantly than I do, but I was like, oh yeah, yeah, that's
right.
It could be a few sentences.
That's right.
And I was like, oh my God, I am not like I've come to a new point.
It's just that I didn't realize the extent to which my thinking was always, and I always
felt like that was such a big move to realize that, hey, I distinguish four things.
And by the way, all four of them are part of one thing.
I always thought that was a really interesting, insightful moment for me as I was writing
it.
And people have always responded positively to it or nudgingly or whatever.
But I'm like, oh my God, it's just nonstop in this, in the section that we're dealing
with especially is just relentless.
Yeah, I mean, your focus on indistinction is so present in this section, like, and that,
I mean, if there, this might be reductive, but I mean, if there is like a thesis for this
brief little section, it seems to be like, all there is, is the tension between consistency
and inconsistency.
And inconsistency.
Right.
Or coherence and incoherence or truth and untruth.
So it's like, there's no, I mean, you might like vacillate sort of between the poles, but
there, there is no distinct distinctiveness, you know, between, between object and subject
and so on.
Or to put it in Muckelbauer's, you could say that there's that constant tension or moving
back between, you know, the sweeping movement of the topoi and the indistinction of, well,
just indistinction, right?
Indistinction, yeah.
Yeah.
But, but I mean, you didn't, you didn't need Hegel to reach that point about indistinction
either, you know?
I mean, you got a similar orientation through Nietzsche and Deleuze, you know what I mean?
So it's like all of these thinkers are invested in, in some way in that level of indistinction
or ambiguity.
But there's a really great twist.
So for me, there's a passage, paragraph 171, I mean, I just, I was underlining like every
sentence and finally I was just put a big asterisk on the page because I was like, here, here
all is in a paragraph.
But there's one passage where he makes, and this is, he takes the twist one step further
than at least I'm generally familiar with.
So this is on 178, in 171, paragraph 171, page 107.
The sentence is, life in the universal fluid medium.
This is, he's talked about this fluid stuff for several pages and, you know, this is the
becoming and whatever.
Life in the universal.
171 has a couple paragraphs.
Is that first paragraph?
This is in the, this is the first paragraph about a little more than halfway down, ends at
the end of the, towards the end of the line.
Life in the universal fluid medium.
A passage separating out of the shapes becomes, just by so doing, a movement of those shapes
or becomes life as a process.
Okay, so this is a point that's not hard to get, right?
There's the constant push-pull, change and change, you know, changing of things.
And it's by the separating out of the moments and the shapes that it happens, right?
That, that, that, that.
So in other words, through the form of forms, you know, or shapes, movement occurs, right?
Life as a process.
The simple universal fluid medium is the, in itself, right?
There it is, right?
That is, it's the, it's the medium.
And the difference of the shapes is the other.
So you have this coagulation of shapes, the, and then decoherence.
Then coagulation of shapes, the decoherence, right?
We're very, very familiar with this.
And then this is where, this is the twist that gets me, is this next sentence.
But this fluid medium itself becomes the other through this difference.
For now it is for the difference, which exists in and for itself, and consequently is the ceaseless
movement by which the passive medium is consumed.
And that to me was a, just a step further than the usual, like, dissolution, solution, dissolution.
It's like, it's, oh, by the way, that dissolution itself is also a moment, though you never think
of that that way.
In other words, the only way I can think of this is things decohere, things go here, things
decohere, things go here.
And he's like, but by the way, if you take that seriously, that moment of decoherence isn't
decoherence.
It is a moment.
And I was like, holy fuck.
That's why, like, for instance, Nietzsche has this antagonism towards the dialectical quality
of his Dionysus, and I'm like, that's it.
Now I see, I get a sense of what he, what Nietzsche wasn't recognizing in his youthful
writing was that by talking about it in terms of, like, the stream of becoming or Heraclitus's
stream, that's creating it as a moment, meaning as a sort of form, a formless form of a moment,
which is to say it's wrong, which is to say it's an inaccurate rendering to think of it
as becoming in that sense.
I was like, that, that, for me, it was this moment of, like, whoa, that's another turn
that I had not thought of before.
Formlessness, formlessness is itself a form.
It's a form.
Yeah.
That's right.
And it's necessary.
Yeah.
That's, yeah.
I mean, but that, I was just like, that's a next, that's next level for me, was, was really
kind of seeing that, like, oh, it's not just a question of saying, hey, we're all in this
formless fluid becoming that occasionally assumes shapes.
It's like, no, no, no, we're not.
That's not the, it's not like the real reality is the formless movement, because that's another
moment.
Right.
Yeah.
And I'm like, oh, you know, for me, that was just a epiphy, you know, epiphany or whatever.
So to bring this back to your stuff on indistinction, so yesterday I taught the final class in my
history of rhetoric course, and I've, for the last, the two times that I've taught it
now, the last thing I teach is, John, your short piece, the return to the question, the
what is rhetoric one, and it just then becomes like the opportunity, like, all right, you've
spent the entire semester kind of asking that question, let's, you know, let's think about
it as the, like, in terms of the, like, as the, in the form of the question.
And one of my students asked at some point, like, is rhetoric limited by not being definable?
And, yeah, I mean, it was a good question.
Yeah, it's a very good question.
And I had to think through it a little bit, and I stumbled on a very similar kind of response,
is that, like, yes, but not any more than anything else is limited by having any other
kind of definition, because to say that it is not definable is itself a definition, to
say that it is, you know, not, whatever it is, that is still a, you know, like, when I
recognition, yeah, like, when I, when I define rhetoric instrumentally, it opens up one kind
of field of things that I can do with it.
Like, when I teach, you know, my writing to persuade class, and I just sort of run with
Aristotle's definition of rhetoric, then rhetoric becomes and does one kind of thing.
And then when that thought boy gets cut by asking, you know, like, by attending to the form of
the question, what is rhetoric, and it becomes that indistinguishable, unlimited thing, that
now just limits it in a kind of a, in a different, in a different way.
And I think that's exactly what's going on here is that, like, I mean, because there are the
two, there's like the, you know, the dissolution becoming equal of everything, and then the shaping
into its parts, and then coming back to that dissolution, and the way in which that dissolution
happens is informed by the, the, the, the, the prior distinguishment, right?
So there are, there are multiple ways, like, there's not just one way things become indistinguishable,
right?
That there are, there are styles of becoming indistinguishable.
No, this is just says the, the, the, um, on the next page, and like I said, that paragraph
for me was just huge, 171, um, on the next page, thus the simple substance of life is the
splitting of itself into shapes, and at the same time, the dissolution of these existing
differences.
Again, clear, like, that's, that's old school, right?
And then this is the twist, is, and the dissolution of the splitting up is just as much a splitting
up and a forming of members, right?
And, and it's that next move, because you could easily say, well, that dissolution is
the condition for the future forming of other members, but that's not what he's saying, right?
Right.
He's saying the dissolution itself is the formation of members, and that's, that's where I, for
me, that's just that one hook more, because I think, you know, in terms of that essay,
for instance, I remember my motivation in writing it, and it was, on the one hand, I'm so sick
of this question, what is rhetoric, and on the other hand, it's the only question you
can ask, right?
Like, and I'm also, I'm equally sick of the dismissals of that question, you know?
So, so, I mean, it was this kind of, like, stop asking what is rhetoric, and stop telling
people to stop asking what is rhetoric.
And for me, like, it's the simultaneity that's the key there, like, between coherence and
incoherence, like, you have to think them temporally as happening at the, at the same
time, basically.
That's right.
Because if, to take shape, you need incoherence, to, like, so it's, and there's not one coming
after another, it's, it's almost harder.
That's the hard part.
Right.
Because, you know, I totally agree with you, because it is, it is, and I think it's conventionally
easy to say, dissolution taking shape, dissolution taking shape.
And I get that, right?
I get, that's the conventional understanding of becoming that I have always had, right?
But to think that dissolution itself as the taking shape of a, on another level.
And I'm like, well, that's, that's a move that to me is new, right?
Like, or that I hadn't thought fully.
Yeah.
Think of, like, the, the, the, the dissolution taking shape, dissolution taking shape posits
a form content relationship, right?
Because there's always some kind of prior content that's getting taken up into a form.
And then that would, like, there would, like, content would have to mediate the shift from
one kind of set of forms to another set of forms.
But what's going on here is, is, I mean, I think resonates with Nietzsche, is that form
only ever takes up form as its object.
As its object.
Yes, yes, yes, I like that.
Yeah.
Right.
You need, you need the breaking down.
Content is always, content is always form.
Like, the, the, the, the thing that we call content is kind of inconsequential.
Like, form is always the content of another form, another force.
And the, and the content of a form could always become the form for another content.
For another content.
I mean, it doesn't, the distinctions are always merely relative and depending on where you're
standing and what you're looking at, you know?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
But it makes all the difference.
I mean, that's where in the what is rhetoric question, for instance, it matters how you
answer that, right?
Like, it matters, if you answer it Aristotle's way, that's going to lead you to look at certain
kinds of things and attend to certain kinds of things.
If you answer it in Vitanza's way, it's going to lead you to a different kind of thing,
right?
Right.
So it, it matters, which answer, so it's not like.
It's the only thing that matters.
Right.
Yeah.
And I mean, and, and different, so sort of take the, the other, like, end of that equation
or this, this oppositional logic.
Like, difference also is taking shape, right?
The, the usual way of thinking difference or the one that I see most often is that difference
is sort of pre-individual, like, substance.
That's right, pre-individual singularities, right.
Right, right.
And here, it's like, I mean, you just can't think of it in terms of that kind of linear
or temporal logic.
Like, they have to be together.
You have to force them together in your mind somehow, you know?
Well, this is where you got, I mean, for the longest time, I've, my particular linchpin
on this was the notion of the genius, the individual genius, right?
Because that's been a target.
As long as I've been in academia, that's been a punching bag, right?
Like, the image of the individual genius.
Right.
And I've always been like, well, I don't see what's, I mean, I, it just seems to me from
living in the world that there are clearly individual geniuses, right?
Like, there are people who, for whatever reason, right, like, are just fucking geniuses.
And, but, and that's been a target all along.
But it's precisely to say, you have to really circumscribe the notion of the individual in
in a completely, like, totally cordoned off way.
And if you don't cordon it off like that, individual itself is not a problem, right?
Like, the notion, so, so I actually feel myself heading much more towards the importance of
things like choice, right?
Like, the decisions that you make, make a difference.
The choices that an individual consciousness makes.
Because an individual consciousness, it isn't an individual consciousness in that kind of,
you know, sort of sectioned off way.
And so, therefore, all we've done is we've changed the notion of the individual to say,
that thing is obviously social.
It's just a particular configuration of the social that's different than a group of people.
But we know a group of people are capable of behaving just as stupidly as an individual,
you know, like, it doesn't matter how many there are.
It's not like, oh, well, if you have 20, then you're going to have better decisions than
if you have one.
That's just not true, right?
Right.
It depends on the one, and it depends on the 20, and it depends on, you know, a host.
Especially depends on the configuration of each one, right?
I mean, I get the taking on the genius as the punching bag.
If you think, you know, much more atomistically, where it's something about, you know, the bounded
individual that has the better qualities, right?
But if you think of the individual as nothing more than the individual intersection of a
handful of things, like, whoa, wow, this one, like, within this general constellation, at
this moment, this set of intersections has got a whole lot more resonance and a whole
lot more different directions than other places.
But if you took that, you know, it would be, I think part of the problem with the genius
is, like, the notion that, well, if you took that genius and you plopped them to any other
context, they're still a genius.
You'd be fine.
Right, yeah.
But that's not the case, right?
That, you know, the genius...
Well, I don't even know what that would mean.
I mean, when you think about it a little bit, it's like, I mean, if you take something
out of its context, then it's not that thing, right?
It's not that thing.
Then it's something else.
I mean, I suppose there are some renaissance men or renaissance people that are kind of
just good at everything, but that's pretty rare.
You know what I mean?
Like, there's geniuses in certain sports and they wouldn't translate to other sports, you
know, if you want to think about it.
But you couldn't, it doesn't, but it sort of doesn't matter.
Like, to me, if someone has evolved to a certain point by age 30, 20, 10, it doesn't matter
what that number is.
And then you put them somewhere else, that's just in a different ecology.
You can't forget the 10, 20 years.
Like, they don't disappear just because they moved countries or whatever else.
Like, so to me, having cultivated a series of capacities for this thing, they might become
good at something different and you never, you know, but...
Yeah, for sure.
And they might become good at nothing, but that doesn't, it doesn't speak to, like, you
know, we are just the accumulation of those contextual things in a singular fashion.
But the notion of the individual, and again, the things that go along with it, like choice,
reason, all of those sort of, you know, enlightenment values that people are beating up on.
And I'm like, I mean, I've just found myself more and more politically, like, it matters
what choices you make.
Like, your choices, that's it.
It makes it...
Now, I recognize that that doesn't mean that everybody is equally capable of making every
choice.
No.
I've never said, you know, I don't think anything like that at all.
It's not, that's where you have to distinguish between a notion of a socialized conception
of the individual and that discreet, hermetically sealed Cartesian, you know, individual.
Like, that thing just seems like, of course, that's, no, no one's talking about that, right?
You're all talking about this sort of matrix of, you know, but in that context, the notion
of the individual choice, rationality, all of those punching bags are like, why are those
things a problem?
Those things like perfectly good values.
Well, why even take them up as punching?
For one thing, they've been beaten to death.
So, like, wouldn't it be far more interesting to say, like, all right, what does choice look
like given, you know, this set of configurations?
And perhaps that, you know, that category can be given new life.
So, like, what happened, what is choice if it's not, you know, sort of the retreat into
the cogito to sort of, like, survey a world independent of oneself and then choose to act
within it or not act within it, right?
It's one of those things that, for me, for instance, I remember having this conversation
with Diane about a decade ago, and she was huge into Derrida on the decision, right?
The decision is a cutting that can't be programmed in advance, must have this moment of absolute.
And I'm like, why does Derrida shy away from the word choice?
Because he does, right?
Like, I mean, he does.
He, you know, in Derrida's writing, the word choice is a bad guy, right?
But the word decision is a good guy.
Like, wait, to me, you got to say, and if he wants to say choice has historically been
configured as that hermetically, you know, and the reason I go, and fine, that's a perfectly
great explanation, but I have not read him do that anywhere.
And so I'm like, all of those Derridians who want to take up Derrida on the decision
and Derrida on justice, right, but want to refuse these categories of, you know, these
traditional humanistic categories, and I'm like, wait, wait, wait, you have to explain
to me why you're saying I'm pro-decision and not pro-choice, right?
Why I think the concept of the decision as a cut is an important concept in Derrida, and
why I think the refusal, you have to, to me, you have to take that up.
You have to, uh, at least negotiate that, but, yeah.
Well, I mean, I think actually pulling, I mean, bringing up the pro-choice thing is that
there's the, I mean, there's the whole Christian morality baggage that comes along with the
notion of the choice, so that, so that, like, accountability comes along with the choice
that one makes, and they get schematized within this whole ethical, like, sphere.
Yeah, I mean, it might just be a, yeah, it might just be a problem of terminology, I mean,
because Derrida shied away from the subject, too, right, he didn't talk about subjectivity
all that much, I mean, and that's because it's associated with the cogito and whatever,
so it's like, I mean, you know, and people like Lacan took it up, but most of the post-structuralist
theorists, they got rid of subjectivity, right, for pretty obvious reasons, you know,
terminological reasons.
But if you say, but if you say, and I think that you can follow Althusser and others,
if you say subjectivity is nothing but, right, it is the kind of coherence of, you know, just
what Hegel's talking about here in terms of, I mean, all he's talking about is the formulation
of self-consciousness, right, that's what he's interested in at this juncture.
Well, all self-consciousness is, is this, you know, series of what other, I mean, other
in the, you know, the technical sense, this series of relations to otherness, that's all
self-consciousness is, and if that's the case, then self-consciousness, the humanistic subjectivity,
choice, these things aren't in and of themselves problems, right, they are in fact just how things
operate, and it's kind of a disservice to, to sort of shunt a version of them aside, and again,
I get the political reasons by saying not everyone gets to make the same choices that
you get to make, and often, and Nathaniel, you're absolutely right, the notion of choice
gets hooked into this Christian ethics that is, is a problem, right, that everyone should
choose, you know, the thing that they tell you to choose, and that's, choice means conformity,
not choice, right, but nevertheless, it's not the category itself that's at stake, it's the
way that it's been taken up in a particular discourse.
Well, it just seems, like, ironic that for a, a critical move that wants to champion the
complexity of the world would take such a reductive notion of something like, like, choice, right,
to say that, oh, well, choice has to be packaged this way, and it has to be attached to these
other things, and because of that, we have to jettison it, and move beyond it in some kind
of way, right, well, no, like, follow the trail of the things that don't work, and then see
how it gets reshaped as you do it.
Right, right, but I get it, too, I mean, I also would say I have a sympathy for the rejection
of choice, and simply because I remember those moments in my education, right, where it was
like, ah, choice, individualism, right, like, you know, so for me, I had to go through that,
like, I had to go through the rejection of, you know, anything that would be associated
with the Enlightenment, or let's just call it humanism is a better word, I think, but anything
associated with the humanistic value structure, you know, affiliated with that in order to
get to a point, and that would be Hegel's point, right, like, you got to go through, you
can't, you can't skip it, right, you can't just jump to the point where, ah, now choice
means something different, you have to go through the negotiation.
I do feel still, like, an allergy to some of those terms, choice, and then freedom, especially,
like, I see the word freedom, and I'm like, oh, God, like, it's just, I mean, it's so Kantian,
you know, and, but obviously, the way Hegel's using it is such a convoluted, like, paradoxical
notion of freedom, so it's like, it's freedom through the determinism, you know, you have to
pass through the determinism to actually achieve what he calls freedom, so it's not, it ends
up not being freedom, basically, but still with, like, a twist on it that gives you, I mean,
it does give you some version of agency, like you were kind of talking about, like, you should
Still think about your own choices and be careful with your own decisions, you know?
And everything in this book, that's all it does to me, is all these concepts that are
my allergy, like, essence, truth, like, all it's done is beat up on those concepts to the
point where I'm just like, I don't know what the fuck they mean anymore, right? Like, I don't
have any, or rather, maybe the better way of saying it is, in this moment, essence means
this, but at this other moment, essence is going to mean the, like, literally the opposite
of that, and then subsequently, it will mean something that's not the opposite exactly, but
a kind of reformulated, you know, and maybe that's an advantage. It's interesting, because
I've always kind of had an aversion to reading old stuff, Nietzsche being a big exception, but
I just don't like reading old stuff. But one of the things that, in this case, it has forced
me to do, and maybe it's because Hegel's amazing, I don't know, but it's forced me to confront
those vocabulary conceptual allergies, because you can't read this, and either that, or I'm just
going to be who I was when I started reading, which is just generally suspicious and skeptical
of anything. And I felt, I feel like once I opened a little bit, or once somehow I was able to even
begin reading this, everything, all of the conceptual sort of edifice has been at stake, you know, and I
find myself way more careful. Like, essence is one for me that this book has clearly done it to, the
word essence, because I have had an aversion to the notion of essence for 20 years. And anytime I hear
an essence, or someone talking about an essence, I'm, you know, I'm a good feminist, right? Like,
that's bad, right? And now I'm like, essence is actually the only thing you got, guys.
Yeah.
It's just differently thought, you know.
It might still be bad, but it's sort of inescapable, you know what I mean?
That's how I feel like it is here. You know, it's like, it still produces consequences that
might be bad, but it's, it's for Hegel, it's the, it's the movement of spirit. I mean, so
it's like, in his system, you don't get away from it. Simple.
But it's also, but the essence isn't, again, a thing that exists in and of itself, right?
And that, if essence isn't that, then, then you like, then a lot of the teeth of criticizing
it, like, get taken away. I mean, for me, that big move is the way that he reconfigures the
language of universality, which, you know, is not a domain that creates an equality between
every, everybody and then allows sort of like a freedom to act and the moralism that comes
along with it. But like, universality is only ever deployed within like specific sets of
relationships. And so universality then means that like, it's never like you, universals are
never equal to each other. Think about that for a second, right? And, and, you know, like
think about a whole discourse of, of essences and, you know, like a humanist privileging of
the human and, and even like political, like rights. I mean, they're all premised on a, on
a notion of universality that equalizes, like that says, you know, what this woman equals this
woman equals this woman in terms of their femininity. And this citizen equals this citizen equals this
citizen in terms of their relationship to the state. And here, this is like, think about the,
the universal term of the eye, which is only ever this cons compound complex set of like,
like, like, like, yeah, process of differentiating through a universal schema. Right. Like that,
that to me is, is really fascinating. I, I do have a feeling that the, one of the main reasons why
Hegel has not been taken up really at all in rhetoric is simply because of the terminology,
because as you're saying, there's, there's a wild contingency in the fabric of this entire
system and book, whatever, all of Hegel's writing is, is like obsessed with the contingency of
relations. And that's what rhetoric has been trying to cultivate for the past couple decades,
right. Is a, is a focus on context and contingency. I feel like the, the terminology of essence,
the universal, the subject spirit, that just that has made people unwilling to, um, sort of assume
him as a, as a figure for rhetoric, you know? I think you're right. I mean, I think that there's,
and I do, I think that one of the things reading this has done is it's put all of those concepts
back into play, uh, in ways that I, you know, I have, I've just had those allergies to them.
Right.
I think you're right. And it, it makes, it makes reading like a completely new kind of experience
too, you know, because I can't rely, uh, on the things that I like, okay, that's a bad thing. I want
to kind of stay away from that. And like, yeah, go contingency, bad universality. And he's like,
no, no, no, no. You only get contingency through universality. Like there's no, there's no alternative.
And it's like, whoa, wait, hold on a second. I thought, and I guess for me, I realized the extent
to which, uh, maybe you realize the tribalisms that are built into your own thinking that you're not
even necessarily too terribly cognizant of. It's like, okay, yes, I do self-identify as this kind
of anti-humanist. And even though everything that I write is kind of problematizing the anti
in anti-humanism, nevertheless, I still feel a draw to that. And this is sort of pushing me
to realize like, actually, John, you're way more of a, you know, anti-human, you know,
you're way more tribal about that than you realize at the level of understanding. I mean,
we've just talked about, you know, essence, universal freedom, like these terms. And like,
yeah, uh, I, it forces me, it has forced me to read. I mean, in conjunction with you guys,
right? Like, cause I, I don't know that I would have done, been able to do this by myself. I don't
think that I would have, you know, I would have, I would have read it and I would have gleaned from
it the reasons that Deleuze dislikes Hegel because that's what I sort of knew going into it. Even though
I'd wanted the whole point in reading, it would have been for me to open up, but I don't know that I
could have, I could have done that, you know, maybe. No, I don't think I ever would have had
as, as strong of a handle on Hegel if we hadn't done this podcast or whatever, you know, like I,
I was getting my Hegel through Zizek and I was sort of comfortable with that. I was like, well,
his version of Hegel is kind of readable and, uh, seductive. And I was like, do I really want to get
into the weeds with the real thing? And since we have, I mean, it's been like, now I can quote Hegel
confidently and not like sort of, you know, uh, hesitantly without really knowing if what I'm
saying has purchase on the text. I see desire on 167. Ah, there we go. So we don't have, we can start at
174. And it pops up earlier as well. Like it's been, we, we've touched on desire, but only in
passing previously. Right. I have one sentence here. Oh, go ahead. I was just going to say, I don't,
I don't totally know where to begin with it. So I was just curious if either of you, like that resonated
with more with either of you and, and, and you have a passage you would want to go to, or if you have a
take on it, I wouldn't mind reading a little bit of it out loud.
Hmm. Uh, I mean, I have one sentence here. I could, I could pull from 167, but, and I have a very
sort of boring take on it, but, uh, it's, it goes, yeah, this unity, this unity must become essential
to self-consciousness, which is to say self-consciousness is desire full stop. So, I mean,
he's just fully equating self-consciousness and desire there. And to me, it kind of felt like, uh,
it reminded me of Derrida's auto affection for some reason, you know, where it's just like the loops,
the sort of tautology of, of subjectivity where, um, it's always referring to itself and in some ways
appropriating and depropriating otherness. Right. So desire, at least for me in this section,
is, is a word for that looping process of, uh, of individuation. So in other words, that,
that like self-consciousness in order to produce itself and creates an other, creates a distance
between itself and that projected other, and then that distance and overcomes it. And so that,
so the distance, the differentiation is the desire and the overcoming of it is the satisfaction of that
desire. Yeah. My take is it's the second part. It's the overcoming that is the desire, right? Like that,
uh, my take of how he uses desire in the past that you just quoted, but also the later stuff
is that desire is the overcoming, uh, desire is the reunification moment, meaning this sort of
bringing back into the for itself, um, of the, of the in itself. So that's interesting because then desire
would be an accomplishment. It would be, it would be an end point. Well, desire is the thing that drives
the unification, the, the, the, the reunification. It's not, it's not an end point so much as that's the...
So desire is always a desire for completeness?
Right. Like desire, in that sense, the desire, or for some provisional, of course, unification.
What self-consciousness is desire means is that the self always wants to be complete, right? That it is.
So you can see how this, at least for me, you can see how it feeds into the psychoanalytic
interpretation that Lacan, you know, will, will give it and Žižek after that, that, uh, you know,
and so it's the real later, but, uh, but so if we look at it on 174, 175, um, or 175, um, desire
and the self-certainty obtained in its gratification are conditioned by the object for self-certainty comes
from superseding this other. In order that this supersession can take place, there must be this
other. So, um, so desire obtained in the, in its gratification, that's, it's the drive for
the unification of self-consciousness in relationship to the object, right? So that, oh, I get what,
I know what it is, right? Like that, that, that sort of realization and, you know, the various
stages of it. So it is in fact something other than self-consciousness that is the essence
of desire. And, and through this experience, self-consciousness has itself realized this
truth, but at the same time, it is no less absolutely for itself. It is only so by superseding
the object, and it must experience its satisfaction for its truth. So there is this sense, I mean,
it may well be that it's kind of both sides of that, but it seems to me like the emphasis
here really is on the, the bringing back into, uh, uh, uh, the fold component, the, the, the,
the aufhebung, right? Uh, uh, uh, side of things rather than the negating side of things.
Mm-hmm. Yeah. But I mean, like, like we were talking about at the beginning, like the simultaneity
of whatever terms you want, consistency and inconsistency. I think here it's, it's the object of desire
is sort of the perpetuation of desire. Right. If you're, if you take it in the, the psychoanalytic
vein, it can't be satisfied in terms of like a concrete actualization. Desire is, this is G-Jack's
take, whatever. I'm just parroting that, but desire is satisfied through its perpetuation.
Right. So like, the, the, the object is simultaneous with it's the loss of the object. So it's like
that constant reaching and then not attaining, you know what I mean? And I think you initially
were taking some issue with these characterizations, right, John? Because it's, it's a desire based
on failure. Right. Failed actualization. Yeah. Right. Yeah. So, so, but that's, that's the sense
to me of self-consciousness is desire. Like, that, that's in 174. It's, you know, what self-consciousness
does is it wants to appropriate, right? It wants to, you know, and now the thing that it's
appropriated, now, first of all, self-consciousness is not a stable entity as we've learned and nor
is the object. And that's what changes things dramatically. Right. Like if they, if it was like,
ah, there's an I and it just goes out into the world and wants to appropriate things, then
it would be this giant appropriation engine. But insofar as it is not, it is the residue
of, you know, this whole, this whole process and movement, it's hard to call it an appropriation
machine in the same way that I would have three months ago, four months ago. Yeah. I mean,
for the, it certainly can read that way. Like let's not get it. Even for the, for the simple
logical reason that, that appropriation would mean death, actual full appropriation would
mean stability and therefore death. So desire can't desire completion, right? Just logically
in the system, it has to maintain some instability to work. Right. Well, I was just going to say
that this desire seems to be a death drive that, that the desire, like insofar as desire wants
completion, desires its own death. But right, right, right. Yeah. I mean, and then the, the little,
the Žižekian twist on the death drive is precisely that you need that breakdown in the engine for life.
Like, so there's a, there's a big portion of death in the life machine. You know what I mean? So it's
like, you need to constantly break down and encounter the other and collide with the other
in order to maintain any provisional consistency. But again, but even to think that way requires a,
it requires a hypostasizing of both the other and the self in order to think of it that way. And so if you,
if you don't, if you think as he's shown us to think the object and the subject, both as constituted in
this process, you know, if you eliminate all of that and just look at it as subject object, then yeah,
it looks like appropriation machine. But if you look at it as this sort of engine of negation and let's
just call it overcoming, right? Like, cause, cause to me that's desire too, right? So, so the thing,
like when we get to that level of self-consciousness, it's not like there's a phase
change. It's just an accumulation of a series of movements. And so therefore that's where I would
say there is nothing missing there and there is nothing, it's not a death drive anymore than it's
A life drive, right? Like itself, like that whole, that, that one has to hypostasize those two points
in order to think of it as a death drive, right? To think of it as an appropriation of an object when
and that may well be how self-consciousness thinks of it, but that's not how it actually
works, right?
But it is how it works, right? I mean, it is how it works in so far as like the hypostasization
is a movement, right? Like, I mean, it is, it is an act. It's, it's, you know, it doesn't
correspond to an underlying reality, but it is the sort of like tropological, topological,
like carving of the boundaries of something in order to articulate.
But it would be the mistake in understanding, I think, would be self-conscious thinking of
itself as desiring to appropriate the object. That would be the wrong reading, right? Like
that would be the bad reading. That would be the reading that came from hypostasizing subject
object, object distinction. And ignoring the various levels that got us to subject, object
distinction.
Right. But again, that's a moment that's necessary, like we've kind of talked about. That, that
mistake of the understanding, capital U, like that's a moment in the progression of spirit
for Hegel. Yeah. Yeah. And I mean, that's where it's sort of, I, that's where I'd be like,
I mean, I think that, that it may be right in the sense of that's kind of how our organism
works, but the idea that it's necessary seems, you know, uh, unnecessary, right? Like in fact,
because what you're showing to me is what looks and seems to us like appropriation and desire
from an object and, and therefore necessarily failure, it never was, uh, uh, and never has been
me wanting an object, right? That's just, that's a hype, hypostatic mistake that self-consciousness
makes. Um, and so it's not, it's not necessary to, to think of it that like, that's not,
it's just one of the things that we do.
What would recognition look like with, if you're not beginning from the, the, the subject object,
uh, relationship that if the subject object is part of the production of the, you know, the recognition
machine, then like, I mean, what I, what I would still steer away from is the, the seeming necessity
of recognition for Hegel. But I would totally buy that like recognition becomes one, uh, trope
that gets mobilized in sort of cultivating erotic lines of flight, right?
Yeah, it could be a block in Deleuze, in Deleuze's terms, yeah.
It felt, it felt more like repetition. The way he was, uh, using the word, like maybe, I mean,
maybe this is a silly way to look at it, but like recognizing instead of recognizing, like,
it's just like a repetition of, of, of the movement of cognition. And it, and it felt like, uh,
you know, an elaboration of, of the, of Alphabum as well. Um, so. Oh, yeah. I'm excited to talk about
that next time. Yeah. Well, that's fair. And that's my fault. I mean, you guys can keep, you guys can
go, man. I just, no, no, no. I, I, I didn't finish that section. I, I, I read, I got about halfway
through it and was just like, as I was reading the, on, um, Lordship and Bondage, I was just like,
I still don't understand what's going on in the section before. And I found like at least 30%
of my brain was still working through that. So I'm glad that we're staying here. Right. It's
interesting though, because in many ways, what I've been saying for the last like five minutes
is, uh, you know, in, in so far as I'm saying, let's not hypothesize the subject object relations.
It's very much like what we were talking about in terms of vocabulary questions in the previous hour,
where I'm like, you know, here are these categories, choice, freedom, you know, uh,
universality, whatever, whatever. Um, that when you allow them to, to sort of be in play and to not
have, um, some absolute or eternal quality do a lot of interesting work. Right. Uh, and I'm sort of
saying now, like, I don't want to allow, I don't want to allow the subject object distinction to have
a kind of, um, momentary, momentary quality of its own. In other words, you, you could certainly,
and I think that there's a very good reason to suspect this, to say like the moment of self
consciousness is in fact a phase change, right? It's it, or like a phase change where all of that,
the, the, the, the self certainty, the, uh, recognition of objects, those things that came
before it, you know, now to the point of self consciousness, right? Um, the, these things
are, um, I don't know, like, uh, each moment is both a, I mean, this is what he does is what
he wants to say. It is both a sort of continuation of an earlier process, but it's also a different
kind of thing itself. And self consciousness brings into play a sense of desire as being mine,
right? Uh, as being like my, I want, right? And, and that's a phase shift. And so, um, what you
then have to do is to talk about it occurring, I guess, on a couple of different simultaneous levels,
right? Which is that, yes, of course we experience this as our desire. And yet the movement of
consciousness happening beneath that is again, but the word, but beneath is going to be weird
here, right? Within. Yeah. Within, but it's same as, and yet different from, I mean, it becomes hard,
I guess, to try to, I mean, this is one of the great things about Hegel so far is it's hard to pin
down what He thinks about anything because it just depends on what, what page you look at. You
know, it really does. I mean, no word is going to be consistent here. And, and I guess maybe what
I'm trying to do is try to, I'm sensing a kind of non unit, non unitary function of desire that I
want to smear across the more unified, uh, moments. Right. Yeah. I mean, if what you're saying is that
subject to object, uh, uh, relationships can be rethought and, and, and have, you know, like a
different kind of valuable life within this, I completely buy it. Yeah. As long as you don't
think about subject to object as either a, like, like natural things in the world that we orient or
that we court, that our language corresponds to, or B, I would even say just like simply constructed
things that then are out there in the world either. Then I mean, then I would totally be on board that
like subject, object relationships are things that get deployed and then organize, you know, the world
according to a certain logic, but they're also constantly, they themselves are constantly getting
reshaped in their own deployment. I mean, in other words, subject, object relationships are performative
themselves. Right. But, but the, the step, I mean, I think that this is what you're saying,
or maybe just to clarify as a question is, um, not which objects in which subjects, but the very
nature of the subject object relation, meaning exactly. Right. Like, okay. It's not a question of
who fits into that category, but, uh, yeah, but what it even means to have a subject object relation.
So, so yeah, I mean, that's the sense in which you could say, like, I guess for Hegel, you could say,
at least theoretically, you could say like, well, some people hook in at one level and they, that's
kind of where they stay for 70 years, you know, or, and other people get to another level and that's
where they stay. And then other people go a little further, you know, I mean, uh, that that's the sort
of progression, uh, I mean, and it obviously teleological for him, no question, but, but still
like, um, maybe what I'm, maybe what I'm pointing to is that getting stuck at an earlier level might
be a better thing, right? Like in other words, advancing into humanness on, on this register
might in fact be the problem rather than the solution. Right. Yeah. Yeah. No, I think it
could be. I mean, and then it's like, there are so many valences of the dialectic, which is the,
the title of Jameson's sort of long book on Hegel. And he, he kind of takes a similar approach where
it's like Marx's version of Hegel is obviously a more materialistic, uh, orientation. And I don't
think one versus the other, like one's not better than the other. I mean, it's like, it's not like
different things. It's like the word is very different questions. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And yeah,
you can hook into a version of Hegel that kind of suits your sensibility, I think. And that's not
wrong. Like I, I don't, we all do it. Yeah. I don't think using a text is wrong. I mean,
and that meant that might seem like an obvious statement, but like figure out the stuff that works
for you. Right. But I think that, but also I think the lesson of Hegel in the passages that we've
just read is precisely that there's no such thing as using a text, right? There's no, cause that
presumes there's a me and there's a text. And it's like, no, what are you showing us in terms of
object relations, right? That the passage that we read for today in terms of object relations is that
there isn't simply an object there, right? A text, right? Uh, there isn't simply a subject here,
right. Right. That there is only the relational sense. And so another way of saying is you can do
nothing but use texts for your, I mean, that's, that's the only option and it's not appropriation,
right? I mean, it's not me making the text do something that I want it to do any more than it's
the text making me do what it wants me to do. I mean, it's, it's not either of those things,
you know? No, no. But, but against the, the traditional, like kind of, cause most Hegelians,
you know, ironically probably would want to think of themselves as understanding Hegel in his entire,
in the entirety of the system, which is like so against the, the grain of the philosophy,
it seems like. Or certainly the way that we're reading it because that's, I mean, I've watched
lectures on YouTube. There's a lot, I told you about the one guy that I emailed with, you know,
like I've watched his lectures and I'm like, the book you're talking about seems completely foreign
to the book that I'm reading. I mean, really? Like, you know, I mean, he's talking about the same
company, he's like, here's what essence means. I'm like, well, it depends on what page, man.
And he's like, no, no, no. Here's what essence means for Hegel. Like, here's the glossary of Hegelian
terms. I'm like, the one thing I'm learning from Hegel really is that you can't have a glossary
of Hegelian terms because the sense of the word is going to change. Like, like Nathaniel said,
sentence to sentence sometimes, you know, like, oh, well, that's the essence. And like, oh,
a sentence ago when I said that was the essence, that was wrong. It's not the essence.
Yeah, I know. Well, I mean, or I think another way of saying it, maybe this is a more Derridean
way of saying it. Like, if you tried to write the glossary entry for the word essence, you would be
writing in perpetuity, right? Because, you know, I mean, it's not just that, like, things, you know,
it's just not that it's polyphemous. It's that, like, you know, it doesn't matter where you start,
you would instantiate it, you know, in this particular way. And that is necessarily going
to overcome to the next thing. And now you are performing, you know, the Hegelian, right?
Let's do it even better. Let's just say you're going to, you write the glossary of one use of
the word essence in Hegel. Yeah. You don't even have to talk about the glossary of the word Hegel
as it occurs in its many instantiation. Just one use. Yeah. Yeah. Right. Right. Yeah.
You'll be writing forever. Forever. It's a Bordhez story, I'm sure. Or the glossary would just be
these useless tautologies, like essence is essence, you know? And that would be the whole definition.
But it wouldn't be, I mean, he has that, there's that one passage where he says,
I am I as an example of the useless tautology. I was like, that doesn't seem like a useless,
like, haven't you taught me that's not a useless tautology? Which he has, right? Like,
it's kind of, it's like, wait, there's a conditional circularity and a provisionality to that,
you know? So, yeah, but I mean, it's, anytime you get to the
point where you come up with an idea for a Bordhez short story, that means it's a good
conversation as far as I'm concerned.
One of the issues for me with like, uh, the, the traditional, the, the traditionalist kind
of approach with Hegel is like, the difficulty of the writing doesn't mean that you should put
yourself below the writer, right? You don't, you don't have to revere the writer or think of him
as some sort of like inaccessible, like we were talking about earlier, genius. Like you, you have
to put yourself on the same plane in order to produce something, I don't know, either useful or
valuable or interesting to me at least. So that's why the kind of like analytic tradition, they're like
in service of Hegel and they actually fail Hegel ironically in trying to do that, right? Like
they think of themselves as students of these people, of these geniuses, you know? And I feel
like that's just a weird way to go about trying to write anything of worth. I think I use this quote,
this speaks to what you're saying there, Nate. I think I use this quote once before. So, um, but
Deleuze has a quote somewhere where he says there, there, there really are two ways of being a disciple
and one is to say what the master said. And that's what almost everybody does as a disciple is say the
things like Aristotle taught us that, or Hegel taught us that say what the master said. And the other is to do
what the master did, um, which in Aristotle's cases, develop your own taxonomy of flowers or whatever,
you know? And, um, and he said, he said, they, and the next part is they don't need to be, uh,
irreconcilable those two things, but they almost always are. Um, that most, you're either a person
who says what Hegel says or a person who does what Hegel did. Um, you, you, um, adapted that exact
quote for that music thing, that Neil and music thing that we wrote where you're like, look, you can say
what Mark said, or you can do what he did by diagnosing the, right. That's right. I've always,
I've always loved that quote because it just struck me. And for me, Aristotle, I was reading
Aristotle and working with Aristotle at the time. And it just really hit me of like, oh my gosh,
90% of what I do as a student is try to learn what someone said so that I can say it and use it.
And what I often don't do is, is say, well, here's what Aristotle, like instead of ethos,
pathos, and logos and how they work, which are boring, but whatever. Instead, it's like,
Hey, I'm going to look at the world of persuasive speech and try to come up with diagnostic categories
for them. Right. That's what Aristotle did, you know? And that's a really different, I mean,
just think in order to call yourself an Aristotelian, anyone who calls themselves an Aristotelian is,
is in the former category, right? They are, they are people who do, who say what he said and don't
necessarily do what he did. Right. But to say that they're not irreconcilable, I think that's
important as well, because doing what he did doesn't mean abandoning the categories of ethos,
pathos, and logos. What it does do is abandoning that, like, there's the right version of it,
or like, you know, now that I found, it's only after I find out what they are that I can use them
to correctly divide up the world. But if you, again, if you take them as, as tote boy, be like,
all right, how does, like, let's take up ethos as a question and then see how it starts dividing up
the world as I, you know, mobilize it, then you were in some ways double Aristotelian. How can you
double Aristotelian? It's like a Starbucks, like I'm going to go, can I get a double Aristotelian with
the phone? That sounds nice. I might try to order that. Yeah. Yeah. It comes with a side order of
taxonomy. Yeah, but you're right. I mean, assuming a stability of content is what most disciples do.
And in doing that, especially with these, with Hegel or with Derrida, a Derridian or a Nietzschean,
if you're making a glossary of concepts, you are not doing what they did. You are reducing.
The irony being, remember, you didn't take, I think Nathaniel, maybe you were in it, that's the time that I
took a class on Nietzsche. Were you in that class? Yeah. Yeah. So, and remember on day one, I said,
I remember I took a class. There are five things at Nietzsche. That's right. And I'm adding the sixth.
That's right. I mean, I did, I mean, so seriously, so I began the whole thing and I think it encapsulates
because this was for me such a formative moment in my thinking and that had to been a decade ago
where I was like, I took this class once where the guy, where it was Charles Scott and he said,
who I love and I think is brilliant and amazing influence, but he's like, there are five important
lessons of Nietzsche and he enumerates, you know, the eternal return and whatever, whatever. It goes
through the five things. And at the time I came, I remembered what those five things were and wrote
them all out on the board. And I was like, I just, there's such a big part of me that for 10 years
after reading that, and I've always respected and admired Charles, but I'm like, how reductive of a way
is that to read Nietzsche? Because to me, Nietzsche, like the idea that there's five lessons,
like, no, they're not five. I mean, you have to read this stuff. It's not just about the content of
the propositions of the lessons he learned about this or that or whatever, whatever.
And, and so that's how I felt for a very, very long time is that that's just a dismissive way.
And then when it came time to teach, it's like, I, I find a certain actual admiration in that
hypostasizing of these things into lessons. And so my, like where I ended the lecture on that first day
was, and my goal for this semester is going to be to add a sixth thing to this list. Style
is the sixth thing that I wanted to add into it. And it's like, so how do you talk about the
movement of the writing of Nietzsche? Well, you put a sixth thing and you call it style. And so what,
you know, so it was this moment where I was like, wait, maybe that's exactly what Charles had done
with the first five, right? Like is that, is that that hypostasizing moment needn't be necessarily
antagonistic to one that is attentive to the movement of the thinking. And that's to me where
this question of subjectivity becomes really, really important. What we were talking about,
the subject object distinction as well, where I like, I'm resisting the hypostasizing because my
concern is that hypostasizing those positions of subject object eliminates something about the movement
that, that got us there and leads us in a direction that I don't want to go in, though. Maybe I should
be more willing. But preventing to preventing the hype, the hypostasizing move is also a hypostasizing
move, right? That's right. Not allowing it. You're still fixing the boundaries of where it's allowed
To go and where it's, it's not allowed to go into that fixed category, which is that's a fix.
That's so totally right. And that's, that's what I learned from this, that passage that I pointed to
you guys is realizing that the, the fluid moment is a fricking moment, right? Like it's as much a
form as the form, the formless is itself a form. And I was like, that's a twist that I had not really
appreciated prior to that, you know?
This is what I'm really excited about. I'm going to, I started writing a textbook last year. I talked
to you about it, John, and COVID cut it short. And I'm going to, I'm teaching that same class again,
this, this winter, and I'm going to return to what I've already written and just use basically all my
lesson prep time to do that. But like, I am effectively just like, yeah, I'm going to take all of these, um,
Aristotelian terms and try to take them as topo way for like activating the thinking. Like I'm going
to use them as heuristics rather than, you know, I mean, like there are two ways you can approach that.
It's like, all right, I've hypothesized the thing and I know it's wrong. And then through the failure
of the thing, it's going to produce something new, or you don't even like, you don't even worry about
the failure and success. It's like, no, this is just a cut. And it's going to like, just going to,
it's going to create a new set of dynamics. And then I'm going to trace out the, the, like what,
what the, the ramifications of that cut. And then I'm actually going to lead to future cuts.
That's great. And the thing, the, the thing that I have a problem with is when it usually gets taught
in the one-on-one classrooms of the world. It's like, this is ethos and this is pathos and this is low.
And it's like here. And of course what inevitably happens, you know, moment two in that class is,
well, wait, here's an example. Is this ethos or is it pathos? And you go like, well, it's really kind
of more, and you try to partition it and you're like, no, no, no. The point of the exercise isn't
that right. It is, it is not to say it's this or that it is to make a cut. And, but that's a hard
thing because teachers, I mean, that's a hard thing to teach because it's, it's not just the teacher's
fault. It's the students as well. Right. The students want, I mean, we, we want like, tell me your
categories and tell me your taxonomy and how does this fit. And I will learn how to put,
you know, the square peg into the square hole, right? I'll learn that.